على ما يبدو هناك استئناف للرحلات في نور
وفي اتلانتا ايضا ربما
التعاطي مبدئيا مع المشكله واحتواء هذا
العطل
التقني الذي تسبب في هذا الارباك على
مستوى المطارات الامريكيه اذا هناك اشاره
من اداره الطيران الفيدرالي بيسان الى
استئناف رحلات المغادره من المطارين ماذا
في التفاصيل
بالفعل التحديث الرابع من اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه يقول انه هناك تقدم في استعاده
النظام الاخطار نظام الاخطار الجوي بعد
عمليه تعطل حدثت خلال ساعات الليل وهذه
معلومه جديده بان التعطل بدا خلال ساعات
همم
ربما كان قبل الموعد الذي كنا نحن قد
بدانا نسمع في همم به وايضا بان عمليات
اقلاع الطائرات
استئنافات او بدات تستانف في مطايره عفوا
مطرين نور ومطار همم
بسبب همم يقول او تقول هذه التغريده همم
الكثافه او الازدحام الجوي في تلك المناطق
وانهم يتوقعون ان تستانف
عمليات الاقلاع في مطارات اخرى في الساعه
09:00 صباحا لذا موعد الساعه 9:00 صباحا
على ما يبدو كان موعد فيه ربما امل او
ايجابيه اكثر مما كنا نتوقع ولم يكن فقد
موعدا ربما وضع بشكل اا ربما عشوائي لكن
ايضا يعني ننوه ان مطار نور ومطار همم
اتلانتا هم من همم المطارات الكبيره طبعا
في الولايات المتحده مطار اتلانتا يعدلون
بطل نيوزي وليس مطار نيويورك المعروف بجاه
اف كي هذه نقطه مهمه لكن هو ايضا هو ايضا
مطار مهم جدا اضافه الى مطار اتلانتا في
في جورجيا